jamais de pauses en informations
quittons ce qui travaille pour retrouver
les flâneurs les estivants de passage
lorsque l'on voyage l'on pense également
aux petits souvenirs une tradition
touristique bien établie à limoges c'est
logique est sévère la porcelaine que les
touristes se penchent les stands et
magasins installés sur la route
nationale 20 sont aux premières loges
pour les accueillir
décorez penser à une blanche décoré et
sami benjamin bossa mesure pour ce n'est
pas très bon il a du bon la très jolie
et qui ressemble à celui ci qui en
dessous là où prochaine très déco décor
est exactement ça de même le maire avait
que pour les poissons ce domaine et puis
le les assez simple comme celui ci la
marquise de pompadour
qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi même si
les bleus en tête du hit parade des
souvenirs de limoges bibelots bleus de
fourballs mazagran assiette et en règle
générale les articles peu encombrant et
bon marché
ce que certains commerçants appellent la
gamme typiquement touristes les
illustrations sont les mêmes depuis des
années toutes les tentatives de
modernisme aurait échoué
les dessins moderne serait incompatible
avec l'idée que se fait le touriste de
passage de la porcelaine de limoges
si les étrangers apprécient
particulièrement le bleu four les
français eux auraient une prédilection
pour la décoration murale le français il
aime beaucoup la cdapp l'ip
il est resté fidèle a lâché par tous
très coloré très décoré travis de à ces
traditionalistes envoyé beaucoup de jeu
encore de fragonard et des paysages
c'est quand même il aime les quatre
saisons les choses comme cela
et ça marche très bien c'est pour le
touriste le client qui veut ramener une
chose à la femme de ménage qui a gardé
tout tout vous le midi
le parc seront bien quand nous avons des
cars qui peint de vous reviennent de
lourdes
il y à un engouement pour les visages
religieux pour les mêmes chefs
pas mal mais c'est pour marquer limoges
de sucre mais on va débarquer souvenir
notre dame de mont saint-jean montrer
des trucs comme ça va avec la bassée
c'est pour marquer ses occupants quand
on lit partout où vous étiez regarder
mais encore pensions que le choix qui a
donc c'est mieux à paris pour ce
parcours les bibelots là aussi des et
sujet en or aux étrangers traditionnel
anglais ou hollandais s'ajoute cette
année des visiteurs américains canadiens
libanais ou saudia beaucoup se tournent
vers la porcelaine haut de gamme qui
tenterait aussi la clientèle française
des cadres moyens et supérieurs
la qualité existent la qualité existent
mademoiselle nous sommes dues tous
démunis qualité et le touriste le sait
bien